brasil es el segundo país del mundo más
afectado por la pandemia del coronavirus
y se sitúa solamente por detrás de los
eeuu aquí en copacabana una ong ha
organizado un homenaje a las víctimas
600 pañuelos blancos que recuerdan a las
600.000 víctimas del coronavirus pero en
este panorama sombrío hay una buena
noticia en septiembre el 58% de los
municipios brasileños no tuvieron que
registrar ninguna muerte por el joven 19
es el mejor dato de este mayo de 2020
estamos hablando de 3 mil 274 ciudades
la media semanal de muertes también ha
bajado sensiblemente se sitúa en 500
muertes diarias muy por debajo de los
picos de más de 4.000 muertos
registrados en el pasado mes de abril es
el claro resultado de la vacunación que
en brasil avanza aunque es un reto
monumental porque el país tiene más de
213 millones de habitantes hoy el 45 por
ciento de la población está totalmente
inmunizadas estamos hablando de 97
millones de brasileños y el 70% ha
recibido la primera dosis de la vacuna